so a boltzman brain is this idea that in
a long enough Universe a brain will just
emerge in the universe is conscious
without and that neglects the causal
chain of evolution required to produce
that brain and this is where the
computational argument really falls down
because the computation can say I can
calculate the probability of a bolts and
brain and I can and they'll give you a
probability but I can calculate
probability of a Bolts from brain zero
just because the the the space of
possibilities is so large yeah it's like
when start falling ourselves with
numbers that we can't actually measure
and we can't ever conceive of I think it
I think it it it it it doesn't give us a
good explanation and I've become I want
to explain why life is in the universe I
think life is actually novelty minor no
I mean life basically mines novelty
almost from the future and makes it
actualizes in the
present okay life is a novelty minor
uh from the future that is actualized in
the present
y I think so novelty minor first of all
novelty what's the origin of novelty
when you go from boring time to creative
time where is that is it as simple as as
Randomness like you're referring to um I
I am really struggling with Randomness
because I had a really good argument
with yashab about Randomness he said
Randomness doesn't give you free will
that's insane because you just be random
but I think and I think he's right at
that level yeah but I don't think we I
don't think he is right on another level
and it's not about Randomness it's about
it's about
constrained the sound like constrained
opport I'm making this up as I go along
so making this up constrained
opportunity so what I mean is like so
you have to have so that the novel no Y
what is novelty you know this is why I
think is a funny thing you ever want to
discuss AI why I think everyone's kind
of gone AI mad is that they're
misunderstanding um novelty but let's
think about novelty ask what is novelty
so I think novelty is a genuin new
configuration that is not predicted by
the P past right and that you discover
in the present right and um that is
truly different right now everyone says
that some people say that novelty
doesn't exist it's always with precedent
I want to do experiments that show that
that is not the case and it goes back to
a question you asked me a a few moments
ago which is where is the factory yeah
right because I think the same mechanism
that gives us a factory gives us novelty
and I think that that is that is why I'm
so deeply hung up on time I mean of
course I'm wrong but how wrong and I and
I think that that life open opens up
that commentarial space in a way that
the the our current laws of physics or
the as contrived in a deterministic
initial condition Universe even with the
get out of the Multiverse David Deutsch
style which I love by the way but I
don't think is
correct um but it's it's it's kind it's
really
beautiful Multiverse the M the David
Deutsch's conception of the Multiverse
is kind of like given um but I think the
the problem with wave particle duality
and quantum mechanics is not um about
the Multiverse it's about understanding
how determined the past is well I don't
just think that actually this is a a
discussion I was having with Sarah about
that right she was like oh I think we
we've been debating this for a long time
now um about how we how do we reconcile
novelty determinism
indeterminism so okay just to clarify
you both you and Sarah think the
universe is not
deterministic uh I'm I won't speak for
Sarah but I roughly I I think that the
Universe I think the universe is
deterministic looking back in the P back
in the past right but undetermined going
F going forward in the future so I'm
kind of having my cake and eat it eating
it here this is because I fundamentally
don't understand Randomness right as
Yasha told me or other people told me
but if I adopt a new view now which
the new view is the universe is just
non-deterministic but I'd like to refine
that and say the universe appears
deterministic going back in the past but
it's but it's undetermined going forward
in the future so how can we have a
determinist a universe that has
deterministically looking rules that's
non-determined going in the future is
this breakdown in Precision in the
initial conditions and we have to just
stop using initial conditions and start
looking at
trajectories and and how how um the
commentor space behaves in expanding
Universe in time and space and asembly
Theory helps us quantify the transition
to biology and biology appears to be
novelty mining because it's making crazy
stuff you know um that that we are
unique to earth right there are objects
on Earth that are unique to Earth they
will not be found anywhere else because
you can do the commentarial
math uh what was that statement you made
about life
is novelty mining from the future yeah
what's the what's what's the little
element of time that you're introducing
so what I'm kind of meaning is because
the future is bigger than the present
yeah in a deterministic universe how do
you go from the how do how do the how do
the states go from one to another I mean
there's a mismatch right yeah so so that
must mean that you have a little bit of
indeterminism whether that's Randomness
or something else I don't understand I
want to do experiments to formulate a
theory to refine that as we go forward
that might help us explain that and um
and I think that's why I'm so um
determined to try and crack the the
non-life toli transition looking at at
networks and molecules and that might
help us think about it the mechanism but
certainly the future is bigger than the
past in in my conception of the universe
and some conception of the universe and
by the way that's not obvious right
that's what was just kind of the future
being bigger than the
past well that that's one statement and
then the statement that the universe is
not big enough to contain the future is
another statement yeah yeah yeah yeah I
that one is a big one I that a really
big one I think so I think it but I
think it's
entirely because look we have the second
law and right now I mean I'm we don't
need the second law if the future's
bigger than the past it follows
naturally right so why are we
retrofitting all these these sticking
plasters onto our reality to hold on to
a Timeless Universe yeah but that's
because it's kind of difficult to
imagine the universe
that's that can't contain the future but
it's not really exciting it's very
exciting but
it's it's hard uh I mean we're we're
humans on Earth and we have a very kind
of four-dimensional conception of the
world of 3D plus time it's just hard to
Inuit it a world where what does that
even mean a universe that can't contain
the
future yeah it's kind of it's kind of
crazy but obvious weird I mean I I
suppose it sounds obvious yeah if it's
true but the nice thing is you can so
what I I mean so the reason why assembly
Theory turned me onto that was that you
let's let's just start in the present
and look at all the complex molecules
and go backwards in time and understand
how evolutionary processes go gave rise
to them it's not in it's not at all
obvious the taxo which is a complex one
of the most complex natural products
produced by biology was going to be
invented by biology it's a accident you
know taxo is unique to Earth there's no
taxo elsewhere in the universe and taxo
was
not decided by the initial conditions it
was decided by this kind of the this
interplay between the so the past simply
is embedded in the present it gives some
features but why the past doesn't map to
the Future one to one is because the
universe is too big to contain itself
that gives space for creativity novelty
and and un some things which are
unpredictable